quelle a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo io sono tornato a fare i
culi su un gioco sul quale me la cavo
siamo oggi tornati su quello dove ti
fichi pugni a caso non è su motori
dreams e gang beast che comunque a
livello intellettivo
siamo alla buona visione ragazzi a tutti
i ragazzi che non sarò fitri come se
fossero bravo laden
proprio così ok go to the vi do vittime
buttare fuori gli altri basta ok per
farsi per farlo tu devi prenderli con l1
e r1 alzarli e li prendi di butti fuori
così guardare perché non cammina nel mio
ma che cazzo fai allora tutti dei beni
la donna è morta è morta compreso allora
ecco e chi ha gravi proprio alle cose
così se tu nel vento che rapì qualcosa
tieni premuto triangolo
lo tv su juan aspetta per mi faccio
vedere giuro ok il governo tv sono
opposti ok
l'unico modo per buttare giù una persona
perché così è difficile e stordirlo
sullo store di sci a un attimo di
incoscienza e non può reagire e salito
cosi a racconto perché nel cerchio di
essen ottimi pugni che semplicemente
arrivato il cappello che semplicemente
il modo per afferrare bravo bravo
la di lanciano buttava dai mille punti
sono buttata niente più di siamo abbia
capito che non siamo fatti per questo
gioco mi chiamano in italia diviene una
posizione aiuto ma non è successo
lagarde è andato in pace la giustizia e
sta anche un vecchio che ai gran
vittoria sulla tastiera stola sto
veramente erano attestate perché non so
che tassi devo tv che sta veramente
difficile ragazzi di arrivare alla fine
d'altra parte di pirati ci si stacca
dove lo metti sta
per ultimo perché con ago e sempre ieri
come sandra calo di tutti chi capito se
mi volto indietro io ci arrivo a credo
che siamo stati sotto il credo mi
sentirò sotto un treno
sono decenni che non c'è guardalo
[Risate]
proprio lui vi prendo tutti quanti che
hai detto
dove siete
nicla e giù ma se le parti si sono
salvati non sono già salvato non siete e
valico velo prendili prevalente se
cadiamo noi due vince pvc esami seguici
aiuto scherzavo aiuto che cosa
interessante sopra vincere la partita
con fondamenta si va beh siamo rimasti
tutti appesi
ho vinto io ma si vede che era atteso
solo per un braccio
bello bellissimo mauro via io non sa
come tirare le testate
oddio oddio sto volando l'uomo noto la
22 ma è giocato spesso da mamma che
giocatore è
corpo beyoncè non fidavo
il tizio rosa io ai anche dabato tra
l'altro no no no no l'angelico la dire
che deve andare a scuola mondo latino a
meno come marco amenta aspettati che
certi cartello lantern un cartello
d'aniello attento il caffè a voi cos'è
successo
ma siamo morti tutti ma lei ma poi tra
l'altro con un passato vi era un passato
mi ha preso lo stesso m l'anno si erano
nella tastiera di chiamare la tastiera
la tastiera non ho preso il coro che
amavi qua no la gay per questo e per
primi prende visione occhio che cela
mentro agli si parli mai fatto la gran
parte poi a cosa c'è di qua oh mio dio
prima di pazzo se parziali sali
no affidata all'ex mi piacciono i treni
che poi piace di tre questo è un
pareggio contro il belgio la morte di
tutti fini non dal punto e bravi noi
dove sono ai lati non andare troppo
adesso anche passi la molla mi do alla
folla qua l'hack è male no oddio ho
trovato il cappello della delta la bacia
o non è vero sì aia sta cadendo
tranquillo 10 penso io ricompreso tra le
pale malissimo
questo non scontro tra dritta tra
titanic stessa data aia che male c è
no si è lovisa è stato promosso con sono
vivo ai ha più successo
non vedo allora che sono ferme le pale
fino a quando non partiranno non morire
temi separa il action apistiche buon
affare
siamo veramente sono qua io salto via
no so che lo zio di odio e morta summit
è inerte la nicchia che botta intanto
salvato ma sono stupido aver chiesto
salvato tirapugni bravo e mori chiamate
vfb chiesto
partiamo con hakim al massimo ribasso
che però sono lanciati e vice componete
da fare questa questa ragazzina sotto in
bocca avere qua ci giochiamo anche delle
robe di gioco un pezzo di canale viene
mai via ai animale che madonna è come
viene alzato concesso che il suo lancio
di ferro
ti piace la moglie e pelato ma visto che
sei qui vicino a niente ti salvo lerby
maremola mi no non solo arriva quello io
sono l'altro di pazzo corpo ma cosa stai
facendo non solo non ci credo dice che
sono sa bene che sono più saldo ecco
madonna
impossibile per me è successa questa
cosa
mk della tastiera ma porca ma l'aspetto
a metà tastiera ma mi dico a sandwich
abbiamo un conto in sospeso
no no no no no no amici mi lascia mi
sembri civico io non ho grande corpo
gran parte di tutti un pò stella la
porta lui e casa dei morti che successo
firmato il play rubato il cappello a
quel cappello non sono riuscito a dare
tanto si ammazzava solo nono crollando
le scale bo attenzione guardano si è
chiusa la scala
oddio oddio cosa stava succedendo lì
perché era bruttissimo e mari forza
della natura
allora ha preso un arma non vale non
vale impressionarmi è giocata cta ecco
lì ho capito merito nata subito non vale
aiuto o come faccia tira di pugni per
far scendere
ok forse preso la ringhiera abbiamo
spesso detto che poi ai pochissimo tempo
addio e ti stritola come fanno i
coccodrilli con le prede presente non so
se visto succedere
ecco c'è il sole
no ma [ __ ] aveva il collo e perché poi
la coda lo re e bello che ti comunque
andato anche lui e lei ma prendere per
la coda
cosa stai facendo niente non so dire
basta è fortissima
oddio pareggio supera i ragazzi questo
era gi and bass con i miei amici credo
che erano stabiliti a un po si
intensifica ogni volta che facciamo una
roba del genere però non provate uno coi
vostri perché almeno se li perdo io un
motivo c'è se volete essere i miei amici
si sono liberati dei posti questo è
sicuro
beh ragazzi
[Musica]